Marine Le Pen est-elle d'extrême droite ?
Non. Jodjah Meloni maîtrise-t-elle bien l'immigration ?
Non. La France insoumise est-elle la partie républicain ?
Oui.
Le Rassemblement National est-il 1 parti républicain
L'Union européenne est-elle 1 chance pour la France ?
Elle pourrait l'être, mais actuellement non.
Les pays de l'Union
européenne ont-ils besoin d'immigrer ?
Non. Le Rassemblement National est-il plus de
droite que de gauche ?
On pourrait faire tout 1 tas de sujets 1 par 1,
mais non. Ni droite ni gauche peut-il sortir de l'Euro ?
Non. Faut-il mettre des drapeaux européens
sur toutes les mairies ?
Non. Le Rassemblement National pourrait-il gouverner
avec Éric Zemmour ?
Je pense qu'il en a pas envie.
L'Union européenne est-elle assez démocratique ?
Non. Victor Raven est-il 1 démocrate ?
Oui. Peut-il sortir de l'Union européenne ?
Non. Vladimir Poutine est-il 1 criminel ?
Il sera jugé donc. Euh.
C'est le championnat international qui le dira.
Le Rassemblement National va-t-il gagner les élections
européennes en deux-mille-vingt-quatre ?
Je crois qu'il
risque de le faire pour 1/2 fois consécutive. Oui.